is the American dream crumbling a new
poll says that nearly six out of 10
people
say the American Dream is now impossible
to achieve
in this country this report from CNN
money's American Dream poll
conducted by Orca international to young
adults aged 18 to 34 well not even in
that group anywhere that is that
are most likely to feel the dream is
unattainable with sixty-three percent
think it impossible that is incredibly
depressing
at 53 percent up all-american said most
children in the US won't be better off
than their parents and sixty-seven
percent of Americans say they have not
achieve the American dream
I remember when I was in my attempt a
greater 11th grade
I I took a class II things like a social
studies ago of future spacecraft
and the teacher saying that you guys are
gonna be the first generation that
in america that's going to be worse off
their parents and I really like that
like
hit me waco shaped like this and now
it's at that was
twenty years ago and now it's actually
happening how disturbing is this I mean
it as a member a bit generation that
they were good guys I think I have a
very very long I get you a second
hey I my retirement my thing I think the
idea of the American Dream has
definitely evolved you know and I think
it's a lot different for young people
today
you know I think if anything we are the
access generation access means
more toss and I think it should then
ownership Kevin Kelly is a
phenomenal author talks a lot about you
know technology and features and stuff
so that access is better than ownership
I believe that you know we live in the
age who were you know it's buchanan over
today
with greater ease than it is owning a
freakin car arm you can air BnB
you know places all around the world
rather than owning a house I think that
some
it's just a different world we live in
you know like it's better to have access
to things and i own stock right and
I and so I'm perfectly okay with that
you know well
a little a little hope of a depressing
study what do you think I i mean
obviously the American Dream is for a
vague in amorphous and and you know did
it is what you think it is
I but as far as the idea of people not
thinking they are going to do better
than their parents i mean that is
sadly the reality and I think that all
kind of stems from
everything since ronald reagan basically
has been about the dismantling of the
20th century
are the dismantling of love you know
labor unions the dismantling ove
voting right the dismantling up
everything that was
making us a more perfect union and that
was I
to providing you education for people
and and you know the
the this was the country that that
ghetto went to the moon rock all the
stuff that we accomplished but when we
got past the Gilded Age
we're now back to the Gilded Age we're
now back to the you know the .1 percent
and then the rest of us
yeah an I think and and and that he said
the .1 percent by weight cuz it's not
the one person you don't need another
time the one presented
make somewhere around four hundred
thousand dollars which obviously is
great I don't make anywhere near that
but those are the people that are really
the in that top echelons of the Iranian
tiny amount of people who control the
massive amounts of well the tax breaks
they have been given
by taking their money offshore by taking
jobs offshore
by not reinvesting in their companies I
you know in the third is hoarding of
somewhere
that is this is the reagan effect this
is the country we live in now
this is the country where aware what was
once the land of opportunity and is now
not so much I like this we had hoped her
right now we have no hope
why I think there's a generation we
shinri you know every generation should
reassess what it means to do
good you know like are we happy recovery
is assured
are we safer you know are we to refuel
you know more sort of creatively express
you know it's odd that though then
seemed like the scary part to me because
the sixty-three percent are saying that
that Green's impossible even though
the hopi parts that you gave it a pretty
good I
even though those exist these people
still don't think
that whatever the idea the dream is a
happiness that the part i think is
interesting here maybe happiness is
is unattainable I don't know if that
study is is you know it was questioned
you know more meals whether or not they
have the right not to believe that the
dream is impossible whatever you think
the dream is if you're saying it's
impossible things like it might affect
your
happiness right yeah I know whether it
was an index I have objective think
maturing
I guess I think that we have the tools
to be happier are
their parents you know arm or maybe not
I have no I don't obviously don't know
no I mean I I think you're right it a
lot is very subjective
I don't think you know if the American
Dream used to be about I don't know
owning a home in the suburbs clearly
that's not
as much for the goal anymore I N and I
you know I agree with you the that we
were moving away from
the sort of idea I love you know there
was a possessions are about
you know the sort of the me know marked
lines in the sand you to accomplish 22
be a successor to achieve the dream but
as for just the basic
love are you know my parents were
immigrants to this country and they want
their kids have more opportunities they
would have had
if they'd stayed in Spain and I think
that parents want their kids to do
better and now we're looking at
kids realize you that's not going to
happen and that's kinda demoralized yeah
that is a scary thought I want to spin
this positively before we go back to me
one final thought that's gonna make
everyone feel really good about the
futures in my drawer birthday a couple
buzzword in a rather you
a oculus rift I'll be pretty well so you
believe in a mercurial
yeah a bit or that in a virtual happy
world okay very good